[MUSIC PLAYING]
If you had told me 10 years
ago that you'll be playing
Spider-Man in a movie like
this, I would have been like,
you're a liar.
Oh, it's just fizzing
with excitement, you know?
It's like coming into halftime
when a game's already going
and you jump in and it's
like, I got to keep up.
I got to keep up.
He's been to space.
He's become Spider-Man.
He's lost his mentor.
And now his identity
is revealed.
And all he wants to do
is graduate high school
and go to college.
I'm not sure that
these people realize
that I'm not in this movie.
I'm not going to burst
their bubble for them.
What are you looking
forward to seeing
most in this film tonight?
Well, number one,
my homies Benedict
Cumberbatch and Benny Wong.
Got to support the crew.
Got an email from
Kevin Feige saying
it's fast becoming the WCU,
so I'll I'll take that.
Wong Cinematic
Universe, I like it.
I like it definitely.
I get to play the grown
up surrounded by kids.
I can say that.
They're half my age.
They are kids.
Does Ned get to get on
the action on this one?
Oh my goodness, like
you wouldn't believe.
Ned and MJ are killing it.
Yes!
How did it feel to be a
web slinging and flying high?
Oh, man.
It was so much fun.
I loved being able
to do that stuff.
I'm not afraid of
heights in that way.
So I feel really good about it.
Now, what's the difference
between this J Jonah Jameson
and the one you
played previously?
Only the hair, really.
Mr. Dell is truly
a man of science.
Science makes the
world go round.
Now, do you have a favorite
MCU moment in Spider-Man
through your journey?
I like when we're
in the bathroom.
I like when we're in
the bathroom together.
My really cool like Nick Fury
moment is completely undermined
by a toilet flushing.
How does he inspire you?
I bring him to
red carpet events.
So who are you
excited to see tonight?
That kid to play Spider-Man,
whatever his name is.
What?
Who?
And, you know,
the 75 bad guys.
When I first heard
the idea for the movie,
I thought this is impossible.
At the time, I was
like, there's no way
that they could pull this off.
There's no way that
they'll be able to bring
these villains back
into this universe
and make it make sense.
But they did.
Oh, it's always
good to be a bad guy.
It's good being bad.
It's great to be a part
of it, see some old friends,
see some new friends, you know?
I'm just ready--
ready for all of you
to know what I know.